[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las
principales noticias las más destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 en nuestro continente américa a
continuación el sumario de temas que
tenemos para hoy
pues hoy se cumplen de seis meses entre
la declaración de la pandemia de kobe 19
en el mundo en cuestión de meses el
continente americano pasó a ser el foco
de la emergencia hoy lo sigue siendo
pero con dos caras de la moneda algunos
países fuertemente afectados mientras
que otros han conseguido sobrellevar la
situación en este episodio de kobe 19 la
semana en américa con nuestros
corresponsales haremos un balance de
algunos de los casos más destacados del
continente comenzamos
el primer tramo entonces vamos a hablar
en esta ocasión vamos a comenzar
hablando de brasil que es el país
latinoamericano con la mayor cantidad de
casos de contagio es también el segundo
a nivel mundial en el primer tramo de la
pandemia empezó a presentar unas
discrepancias entre las autoridades
sanitarias y las autoridades federales
básicamente el presidente ya ir
bolsonaro vamos a hablar con nuestra
corresponsal a allí y valeria saccone
valeria hola cuál es el balance general
de estos seis meses de pandemia en este
país
bueno la palabra que lo resume podría
ser confusión sabemos que el presidente
de jair bolsonaro desde el inicio ha
considerado el coronavirus como una
gripe sin ya una pequeña gripe y siempre
ha dicho que no era peligroso incluso ha
mantenido que habría que priorizar la
economía sobre la cuarentena y
precisamente por esta razón ha habido
ciertas tiranteces especialmente con los
gobernadores de río de janeiro y de sant
pau los dos estados muy importantes
porque son los estados que llevan la
economía del país pero también hay que
decirlo los dos gobernadores tienen
miras presión iniciales entonces digamos
que la lucha entre ellos no era
solamente por el coronavirus el corolla
mismo es realmente sea politizado y
bolsonaro se ha visto amenazado por dos
políticos yo autor y en san paolo y
wilson widget en río de janeiro que
digamos tienen aspiraciones finalmente
pulsan uytsel para parece que está fuera
de juego porque está siendo investigado
por corrupción a una orden judicial
le quita de medio y encima hay un
impeachment el curso hay otro tema que
también ha generado cierta confusión que
es el tema de la polémica cloroquina
porque a pesar de la suspicacia del
mundo científico bolsonaro siempre ha
dicho que era la solución incluso cuando
él ha contraído el virus casi parecía
que estaba haciendo la publicidad en sus
likes en las redes sociales de este
medicamento y esta polémica ha costado
el puesto a dos ministros de sanidad que
no quisieron implantar el protocolo de
la cloroquina finalmente lo hizo en mayo
el ministro interino para suelo que
desde entonces ocupa este cargo y sólo
para terminar esta parte decir que a
pesar de todo esto la popularidad de
bolsonaro está en alza 37 por ciento de
los encuestados dicen que su gestión es
excelente y los expertos lo atribuyen al
subsidio que él ha concedido de 112
dólares a un tercio de la población
valeria en este primer tramo
o en el primer tramo de los seis meses
de la pandemia de la ciudad de nueva
york fue el punto de contagio en el lado
norte de nuestro continente allí estaba
mamen sal a nuestra corresponsal en la
ciudad de nueva york para contarnos más
detalles
mamen cuál es el balance que se hace
después de estos seis meses después del
caos que vivió la ciudad de nueva york
un importante centro comercial y
financiero en eeuu
sí pues aquí en eeuu como sabéis
desgraciadamente capitanea mos estas
cifras de contagios en el mundo hay más
de 64 millones de infectados en el país
y la cifra de fallecidos ronda ya los
192 mil a lo largo en las últimas 24
horas hemos tenido 38 mil nuevos casos y
aunque es verdad que en estos momentos
los casos continúan empiezan poco a poco
a bajar lo cierto es que el negacionismo
por parte de nuestro presidente que como
sabéis ha ayudado nunca y hemos visto
muy pocas veces con la mascarilla puesta
y muchas menos animando a la gente a
ponérsela pues tampoco ayuda además es
interesante también que el problema que
hemos tenido en este país es que no ha
habido una respuesta reunida conjunta a
una respuesta federal sino que han sido
los propios estados los que han tenido
que gestionarse a sí mismos entonces
para que os hagáis una idea por ejemplo
del estado de nueva york en las últimas
24 horas hemos tenido cinco personas
fallecidas por el cob y 19 mientras que
en arkansas y florida perdón están
siendo 176 en todo el día en todos los
jueves así que esta desigualdad entre
unos estados y otros
es no acabe de solucionar y no acabe de
bajar en cuanto más pueda esos esos
casos de contagios aquí en el estado de
nueva york más concretamente en la
ciudad de nueva york que como decía se
convirtió en el epicentro de esta
pandemia poco a poco nos estamos
recuperando desde luego todavía nos
queda mucho camino por andar pero en el
último mes en los últimos 30 días hemos
conseguido mantener el nivel de
contagios por debajo del 1 por ciento
vamos a hablar ahora de méxico porque
este país sí que fue un caso particular
y dio mucho de qué hablar a nivel
internacional en un inicio el presidente
de ese país andrés manuel lópez obrador
subestimó un poco el alcance de la
pandemia la importancia de tomar medidas
a tiempo hubo un confinamiento y ahora
el país está haciendo frente también a
una muy difícil crisis económica y el
presidente y el gobierno en general han
recibido muchísimas críticas por parte
de los ciudadanos y las autoridades
internacionales en cuanto al manejo que
le han dado a la pandemia del cobi 19
mayo carbonell quien es nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico nos da
más detalles
lo que se ha vivido allí a lo largo de
estos seis meses veamos
el manejo de la pandemia en méxico ha
generado mucha controversia por una
parte el gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador asegura que la estrategia
aplicada es la correcta pues se ha
evitado el colapso la saturación
hospitalaria a pesar de que los
gobiernos anteriores dijo dejaron en las
ruinas al sistema de salud asimismo el
mandatario destaca el esfuerzo de méxico
en el concierto internacional en busca
del desarrollo de una vacuna en
contraparte hay quien ve un completo
fracaso en esta estrategia el ejemplo
más reciente es el de seis ex
secretarios de salud de distintos
gobiernos pasados del pri del pan que se
han unido para plantear al gobierno la
necesidad de un golpe de timón o un
cambio
aseguran que se debe aplicar de manera
masiva pruebas de detección de commit 19
para mapear mejor a la población
infectada y lograr contener el virus en
un plazo de 8 semanas dicen que los 69
mil muertos que de manera oficial hay
registrados en mexico en realidad serían
200.000 dado el subregistro que existe
en respuesta el vocero federal ante la
epidemia hugo lópez gatell ha dicho que
el camino es el de la mitigación más que
la contención y que aplicar de manera
masiva a las pruebas sería un
desperdicio de recursos asimismo se ha
mostrado reacio a dictar de manera
contundente el uso de cubrebocas como
una medida eficaz en respuesta concreta
a este grupo de exfuncionarios dice que
en realidad lo que impulsan es una
fórmula mágica con tintes políticos lo
cierto es que el país llega a los 650
mil contagios y la cifra de muertes
superó las expectativas y los
pronósticos del propio gobierno que
veían esta cantidad de decesos en un
eventual escenario catastrófico hacia el
mes de octubre
y mientras tanto argentina ha tenido uno
de los confinamientos una de las
cuarentenas más largas del mundo allí
todavía varios sectores y varias
provincias siguen todavía con esta
medida para poder mitigar el avance del
coronavirus una de las áreas más
afectadas ha sido el amba el área
metropolitana de la ciudad de buenos
aires- que sigue todavía siendo frente a
esta situación y ha generado por
supuesto varias críticas al gobierno y
también hay un punto importante
argentina venía ya con una crisis
económica muy aguda en el momento en que
peso la el confinamiento y que empezó la
pandemia del cob y 19 en ese país
suramericano para conocer más detalles
vamos a preguntarle cómo está la
situación allí a natalio con soy nuestro
corresponsal en la ciudad de buenos
aires- capital de la república argentina
natalio balance de estos seis meses de
pandemia allí
si como bien decías argentina tiene una
cuarentena de muchos meses se acercan
los 6 comenzó el 20 de marzo y eso
implicó si se quiere un cansancio en la
población un cansancio por un lado por
necesidades económicas para aquellos que
necesitaban salir a trabajar a pesar de
no ser gálvez personal esencial que
tenía autorización pero también para
algunos un cansancio anímico las
necesidades de salir eso implicó que no
oficialmente muchas personas decidieran
salir más allá de la imposición de la
cuarentena pero también que haya una
decisión por parte del estado del estado
nacional y también del estado por
ejemplo de la ciudad de buenos aires- de
ir abriendo actividades por ejemplo la
de bares al aire libre que es una
actividad que se ha abierto hace un par
de semanas que y que ha empezado a
generar más movimiento en la ciudad por
ejemplo pero también al mismo tiempo lo
que estamos viendo es que si en los
primeros meses los contagios y los
fallecimientos están más contenidos
argentinas hoy tiene más de medio millón
de casos muchos ya recuperados y también
ha superado las diez mil muertes y hace
más o menos una semana a diez días
yo diría alrededor de diez
que estamos en un promedio más o menos
de 10.000 casos nuevos diarios
reportados esa es la situación ahora en
argentina acompañada como muy bien
señaladas por una muy difícil situación
económica que ha obligado hasta el
momento al gobierno destinar
aproximadamente 5 puntos del producto
bruto interno a diferentes esquemas de
ayudas que van desde dinero que se
entrega a ciertos sectores sociales que
se llama ingreso este de emergencia
familiar de emergencia perdón que es de
10 mil pesos alrededor de 140 dólares al
cambio actual que se ha entregado en
algunos meses y hoy en día se está
repartiendo unos 9 millones de personas
para ver el alcance de la necesidad
económica de la población argentina en
este contexto de pan de 1.041 natalia
hay que decir que había mucha
expectativa en cuanto a los países del
hemisferio sur en chile argentina
uruguay paraguay porque son países que
han tenido que llevar esta situación en
medio del invierno austral y no se
conocía cómo era el comportamiento de
este virus en unas zonas particulares
como por ejemplo el invierno en zonas
que están en territorio
subtropicales como el norte argentina y
en zonas mucho más frías como el sur en
tierra del fuego hablemos ahora de
bogotá la capital colombiana allí está
luis muñoz periodista de france 24 para
darnos detalles de lo que ha sucedido
allí en la capital colombiana un país
que ha tenido también una cuarentena
bastante larga pero que ya va por su
segunda semana de apertura económica y
sigue registrando una alta tasa de casos
de contagio y tuvo particularidades
medidas el gobierno allí en este país
lluís cuál es el balance que hacen las
autoridades allí en bogotá y qué tal la
situación es parecida a la que comentaba
el compañero natalio de argentina existe
una cierta sensación de respiro pero
también de hartazgo respiro porque las
medidas esta cuarentena tan dura tan
larga hicieron que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos se pudieran reforzar
también que se pudieran traer
respiradores que se pudiera educar
brevemente a la población también en
medidas de autocuidado no de
distanciamiento social pero también de
hartazgo porque estuvo la actividad
económica para durar
de muchos meses se habla mucho también
de las tensiones que ha habido entre el
gobierno nacional de iván duque y la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez esta
última ha sido siempre muy insistente en
que lo primero es son las vidas de las
personas
existe una sensación de que ha empujado
mucho al gobierno a tener esa cuarentena
estricta sin embargo también cabe
destacar que aunque ahora actualmente
colombia es el país con el tercer país
de américa latina con más casos el
primer mes prácticamente en una ciudad
con de 8 millones como bogotá
prácticamente prácticamente no se veía a
nadie por las calles una cosa que cambió
a partir de abril cuando se abrieron más
de 40 actividades para que pudieran
trabajar es ahí cuando empezó también a
dispararse la curva de contagios y
aunque ya hemos superado el pico y como
bien comentaba se estamos recuperando la
actividad que da precaución para saber
cómo va a evolucionar a partir de ahora
la pandemia donde se siguen registrando
cerca de 10.000 casos diarios también
más de 200 muertos y en esta
reactivación queda todavía por esperar
cuando se van a abrir los aeropuertos
para vuelos internacionales ya que los
nacionales abrieron una de septiembre se
espera que cartagena de indias comience
su actividad del 21 de septiembre y
también destacar como nota curiosa que
en cali en la ciudad del pacífico
y ya se ha abierto se ha recuperado en
la capital de la salsa la actividad de
bailes y también las discotecas al aire
libre es que lluís uno de los puntos
importantes de la economía colombiana es
el turismo es un país que estaba
recibiendo muchos turistas extranjeros y
esto frenó contundentemente ese
crecimiento y esa proyección a nivel
internacional en materia turística
también en los primeros meses de esta
pandemia cuando fueron adoptadas las
medidas en la mayoría de los países
latinoamericanos las miradas de los
medios de comunicación y también de la
comunidad internacional estaban
concentrados en una ciudad
latinoamericana en particular en
guayaquil el puerto ecuatoriano en el
pacífico donde no hubo una buena
articulación entre el gobierno nacional
y el gobierno local para el manejo de la
crisis
vimos escenas muy difíciles muy
dolorosas de personas fallecidas que
estaban en las calles de este puerto
ecuatoriano y el desespero de los
ciudadanos y el constante pedido de
ayuda a la comunidad internacional
mientras el número de fallecidos
aumentaba sin control gustavo ortega
quien es el corresponsal de france 24 en
ecuador hace un balance de la situación
que parece que está empezando a mitigar
ya tener un mejor
a seis meses desde la declaratoria de
emergencia sanitaria por el cob y 19 en
ecuador el epidemiólogo de universidad
de las américas esteban ortiz aseguró
que lo peor de la pandemia en el país
andino ya pasó 'ecuador vídeo dos
grandes momentos en la costa y en la
sierra 35 mil muertes sin exceso
aproximadamente según el especialista y
3.5 millones de casos no lograron
diagnosticar se los meses de junio julio
y agosto ser los más críticos durante la
pandemia actualmente la curva
epidemiológica se encuentra en un
proceso de reducción de casos reales en
quito el especialista seguro que se ganó
frenar la batalla contra el virus porque
la población se comportó de mejor manera
se quintuplicó la capacidad de camas
disponibles en la capital ecuatoriana y
se aumentó la cantidad de hospitales en
el país pero en materia económica
todavía existen reclamos de
profesionales impagos el gobierno
central tiene una deuda de 650 millones
de dólares con proveedores del estado
según cifras del ministerio de finanzas
una parte corresponde a proveedores que
elaboran en primera línea de respuesta
ante el commit 19 172 millones de
dólares corresponde al año 2019 y 480
millones corresponden a los primeros 8
meses en el año 2020 paralelamente el
gobierno espera
desembolso del fondo monetario
internacional- por 6.500 millones de
dólares en ecuador se levanta el estado
de sesión luego de seis meses a partir
del lunes 14 de septiembre en quito se
aplicarán 60 medidas transitorias en la
terminación del estado de sección será
obligatorio deporte mascarillas circular
a dos metros de distancia social y el
porte de la cédula de identidad no se
exigirá el uso de mascarillas a la
actividades deportivas que permitan el
distanciamiento social
la circulación vehicular estará regulada
en un plan denominado hoy circula el
transporte terrestre de supermercados
restaurantes permitirán un aforo
frecuencia de 50 por ciento mientras que
cines teatros auditorios abrirán con el
30 por ciento del aforo no podrá
reanudar las actividades en bares
discotecas centros nocturnos gimnasios y
centros entretenimiento pero a pesar del
levantamiento del estado de sección los
contagios continuarán pero no serán como
sus primeras dos grandes olas según
aseguró el especialista en ecuador la
gente ya se encuentra en las calles de
manera absoluta por ello será
fundamental la conciencia ciudadana para
reducir los casos el retomo comunicación
con valeria sakon es nuestra
en brasil en la ciudad de río de janeiro
valeria llama mucho la atención que
antes del inicio de la pandemia ya había
una gran polarización en brasil en torno
a los temas políticos pero el tema de la
pandemia ha generado también un gran
abismo en cuanto a las opiniones que
tienen los brasileños en torno a este
tema en sí es cierto no si existe la
pandemia en torno a las medidas que ha
tomado el gobierno cómo está la sociedad
brasileña al día de hoy cuál es la
percepción que hay en las calles en
torno al tema del cob y 19
bueno yo hablaría de dos sentimientos
que me llaman bastante la atención
desconfianza e incredulidad y voy a
poner dos ejemplos al principio de la
pandemia personará volvió de un viaje
oficial de miami con una comisión de
varios políticos y ministros muchos
contagiados él dijo que no había
contraído el coronavirus y nadie le
creyó hasta el punto que un periódico
pidió a un tribunal que él mostrase el
laudo médico después más tarde él
contrajo la enfermedad y lo dijo y
también en una parte de la población no
se lo creyó y creo que era una maniobra
de distracción de los problemas internos
de las supuestas trabas de corrupción
que salpican a su familia de la misma
forma hay personas desde el inicio como
hemos visto también en otras ciudades
que se han manifestado en contra de la
cuarentena pero también en contra del
uso de la mascarilla en contra de las
medidas
de restricción hay personas que creen
que realmente es una pequeña gripe pero
lo que más me llama la atención son las
personas que no se creen los datos
oficiales recordamos que hubo un momento
que el gobierno prohibió los datos y por
eso he creado un consorcio de
periodistas que todos los días hacen una
publicación independiente de los datos y
más o menos tanto los datos de los
periodistas como los datos oficiales del
ministerio como los datos también del
portal de transparencia coinciden con
pequeñas diferencias pero hay muchas
personas que todavía se quedan en casa
yo conozco a varias personas que no han
salido nunca en seis meses que hacen la
compra online que trabajan online que
hacen su vida social online y que dicen
que todo es una mentira que tienen miedo
y prefieren quedarse encerrados entonces
yo lo que veo es mucha desconfianza
porque precisamente este cambio de
criterios y esto este y de venir el
hecho de que cada ciudad ha hecho la
reapertura de una forma independiente ha
creado mucha desconfianza entre los
ciudadanos y tal vez esa zona
aunque hay en varios países del mundo y
sobre todo aquí en américa latina no
solamente de los brasileños
valeria retomando el tema en eeuu allí
también fue un escenario muy particular
a lo largo de estos seis meses porque
fue el inicio de la campaña para la
presidencia de ese país en un momento
político muy importante porque donald
trump se está jugando su reelección y
obviamente la pandemia no pudo escapar a
la politización en torno a esta campaña
mamen
si está clarísimo que el coronavirus
entró de lleno en esta campaña electoral
y está afectando ambos candidatos quizá
más al presidente donald trump por su
gestión de esta pandemia pues que muchos
ponen en duda para que os hagáis una
idea de momento el presidente ha perdido
el apoyo entre la población blanca mayor
de 65 años una población un sector de
los votantes muy importantes porque fue
decisivo en el 2016 para la elección de
donald trump en estos momentos
saben que encontrar una cura contra la
comey 19 es la mejor baza electoral que
el presidente puede tener en sus manos
no debemos olvidar que nos encontramos
en un momento en el que el país está
tremendamente polarizado con esas olas
de protestas que van de costa a costa
contra la violencia policial contra el
racismo con una economía que no acaba de
recuperarse donde hay más de 16 millones
de desempleados y en medio de todo este
caos pues digamos que encontrar una
solución para acabar con el cobe 19 es
sin duda la mejor baza que puede tener
donald trump
de hecho como sabéis ya ha dicho que esa
vacuna va a estar lista desde el 1 de
noviembre aunque no se hayan terminado
los ensayos clínicos dos días antes de
que se celebren las elecciones
presidenciales que son precisamente el 3
de noviembre así que bueno es importante
también poner esto un poquito en
cuarentena tener un poquito de ojo
porque al final lo que dicen muchos
expertos sanitarios es que ojo porque si
se consigue hacer una vacuna de manera
en tiempo récord de manera rápida que no
sea lo suficientemente efectiva puede
ser incluso más contraproducente que el
hecho de que no haya vacuna porque al
final lo que hace es crear una falsa
sensación de seguridad entre la
población invitar a que ese virus siga
propagándose si nosotros mismos darnos
cuenta
también lo hemos destacado varias veces
en este programa en estos seis meses de
pandemia a costa rica belice y uruguay
son algunos de los países que han sido
catalogados a nivel internacional como
unos de los casos exitosos en el manejo
de esta crisis sanitaria buenos sistemas
hospitalarios disciplina ciudadana y un
poco de suerte digámoslo así ayudo a que
estos países salieran adelante pero en
costa rica las cifras actuales no son
muy alentadoras y allí tal parece que el
panorama está empezando a cambiar y ya
no lo están viendo de una manera tan
positiva cindy regidor que es la
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de san jose nos da más detalles en este
balance
este 6 de septiembre se cumplieron 6
meses desde que costa rica detectó su
primer caso de kobe 19 en este momento
la segunda ola de casos de coronavirus
no da tregua hasta hoy el total de casos
llega a más de 50.000 y las muertes a
más de 500 esta semana se registró la
cifra más alta de muertes en un solo día
24 personas fallecidas a causa del virus
mientras que los casos nuevos diarios
rondan los más de miles es así que
aunque el sistema de salud logró
aumentar la capacidad en camas de
cuidados intensivos en casi 15 veces
entre finales de este mes y principios
del próximo se alcanzaría la capacidad
máxima de ocupación de camas uci para
kobe 19 de continuar esta tendencia la
mitad de las personas con nexo
identificado se contagian en actividades
familiares y sociales dijo el ministerio
de salud el presidente carlos alvarado
hizo un llamado a la población para
revertir esta tendencia de contagio a
pesar de que los servicios hospitalarios
empiezan a dar síntomas de saturación el
país continuará este mes en modalidad de
reapertura controlada pero el presidente
advirtió
y así la tendencia de la pandemia no
cambia entonces se retomarán los cierres
el país que depende de manera
significativa del turismo también ha
empezado a reabrir sus puertas a vuelos
internacionales de algunos países bajo
una serie de requisitos que incluyen la
prueba de kobe 19 con resultado negativo
y un seguro médico costa rica recibe a
personas de 16 estados de eeuu de canadá
reino unido la unión europea japón corea
del sur china tailandia singapur oceanía
y uruguay a pesar de que esta segunda
ola continúa imparable y al finalizar
del año podrían haber unos 2.000 muertos
la situación de este país es mejor que
la de sus vecinos la tasa de letalidad
por kobe 19 es de 10 2% una de las más
bajas de américa y del mundo
el reporte de cindy regidor desde la
ciudad de san josé en costa rica
retomando a argentina a natalio allí en
la ciudad de buenos aires ya usted lo
estaba mencionando un poco en la primera
intervención este doble problema que
tienen las autoridades argentinas una
crisis económica y una crisis sanitaria
como están haciendo frente a la crisis
económica
bueno como decía la crisis económica
tiene varias soluciones si se quiere
hubo intentos de solución
por ejemplo para intentar contener un
aumento del desempleo el gobierno
prohibió los despidos no se puede hacer
despidos sin causa durante la pandemia
lo van extendiendo mes a mes y eso
contuvo un poco también seguramente lo
contuvo que muchos dejaron de buscar
trabajo muchas personas dejaron de
buscar trabajo porque de todos modos
hubo situaciones de despido también de
personas que trabajan en negro o
perdieron la posibilidad de trabajar y
también sus pensiones en en sectores
fabriles por ejemplo y mucho dinero del
estado asistiendo a personas y a
empresas a personas con pagos mensuales
bimestrales depende de cómo lo poder
organizando el estado y también a las
empresas asistiendo con el pago de
salarios en algunos casos para algunos
empleados y para cuentapropistas por
ejemplo y algunos otros sectores de
bajos ingresos profesionales de bajos
ingresos trabajadores de bajos ingresos
la posibilidad de acceder a créditos a
tasa cero para poder ir sosteniéndose
son todos si se quiere parches pero en
paralelo argentinas y logró un éxito si
se quiere de política económica que fue
acordar con los acreedores
internacionales la deuda privada que
mantenía con ellos
también con acreedores de deuda pública
con deuda pública que mantenía con
acreedores en el extranjero y también
con acreedores bajo legislación
argentina que le dio un poco de aire
fiscal o le puede llegar a dar un poco
de aire fiscal hacia el año que viene
pero las perspectivas para este año no
son buenas muchas consultoras se están
calculando que la pérdida de la caída
del producto bruto este año puede ser de
10 puntos después de ya dos años de
recesión en argentina entonces la
situación realmente en términos
económicos no es nada fácil para el país
lluís en bogotá la capital colombiana
este país suramericano fue noticia a
nivel internacional por dos motivos uno
un 'día sin iva' para fomentar el
comercio en pleno confinamiento
obligatorio
en ese país vimos unas imágenes de
personas haciendo fila para poder
comprar y también un poco indisciplina
ciudadana que fue lo que pasó con los
colombianos bien un poco similar a
argentina después de cinco meses de
cuarentena la economía colombiana se vio
muy perjudicada de hecho en el segundo
trimestre el pib había tenido una caída
del 15 por ciento el desempleo en julio
había superado el 21 por ciento también
en el mes de julio
uno de cada tres restaurantes de bogotá
la capital habían cerrado entonces el
gobierno para tratar de reactivar la
economía decidió que iba a hacer tres
jornadas de 'día sin iva' él iba en
colombia es de un 19 por ciento uno de
los más altos de la región y en la
primera jornada celebrada el 19 de junio
hubo imágenes que como bien dices dieron
la vuelta al mundo por aglomeraciones
personas que salían de los centros
comerciales cargadas y sin respetar la
distancia también con unas pocas medidas
de seguridad por parte del gobierno y de
los locales comerciales y esto hizo que
en la segunda jornada celebrada el 3 de
julio de día sin iva
se vieran otro tipo de imágenes más
control de hecho se prohibió con vender
directamente en los establecimientos
electrodomésticos o televisores y se
pasó más a un comercio online que pasó
que en el en la tercera jornada del 19
de julio no se celebró porque en ese
momento precisamente el país vivía uno
de sus peores momentos en tasa de
contagios y muertes por lo que se tuvo
que cancelar para prevenir ya que por
ejemplo en la primera jornada del 19 de
junio de las aglomeraciones se demostró
más tarde que la tasa de contagio se
había visto afectada por por la jornada
de celebración del 'día sin iva' valeria
allí en río de janeiro que es la ciudad
en la que usted se encuentra ha habido
controversia en torno a las cifras que
ha presentado la capital fluminense que
es lo que ha sucedido y valle
bueno en lo que va de pandemia tenemos
más de 10.000 fallecidos y quiero
recordar que el río de janeiro es una
ciudad pero también es un estado que es
el segundo estado más afectado en
términos globales pero si nosotros
miráramos los datos de ríos de género
como un país sería según estudios de la
john hopkins university la el estado más
afectado del mundo con una media de
148,5 muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes o sea por delante de españa
por delante de perú y por delante del
propio brasil eso tal vez explica
también porque aquí en río de janeiro
hay tanta tanto miedo de salir a la
calle entre otras personas también
porque las noticias yo ya lo conté aquí
una vez en un programa las noticias de
fallecimientos entre amigos son muy
numerosas amigos y amigos
parientes colegas de trabajo sin ir más
lejos en este edificio ha habido cuatro
fallecimientos donde yo vivo y uno por
lo menos sido confirmado hay que decir
que hay muchísimos fallecimientos por
síndrome respiratoria aguda que no están
siendo reconocidos como coronavirus
entonces los datos también son un poco
opacos mamen en eeuu hay controversia
porque el presidente de trompa tal
parece que si sabía que este virus era
muy peligroso
así es como sabes son unas entrevistas
que se realizaron en febrero con un
reconocido periodista del washington
post aquí en nueva york pues en las que
se asegura en las entrevistas que
recogen como el presidente don a entrar
le reconoció este periodista que sabe
que el virus es cinco veces más
mortal que cualquier gripe pero justo en
ese momento lo que escuchamos es
turnadas defensas no era eso sino que el
virus no era peligroso y que iba a
desaparecer en cualquier momento son
unas 18 entrevistas aproximadamente que
se recogen en un libro que está a punto
de publicarse y que además también
incluyen pues una serie de valoraciones
por parte de antiguos funcionarios sobre
la gestión de donald trump al que tachan
es muy interesante de no tener un
brújula moral y además de algo que ya
hemos escuchado de ser peligroso para
este país
natalio y en argentina para el cierre
cerca de entre 15.000 y 25.000
ciudadanos de este país se han ido
uruguay porque este país le ha ido muy
bien con el manejo de la pandemia
si se fueron no de forma necesariamente
permanente las solicitudes de residencia
por ahora son menos y tiene que ver por
un lado con lo que bien decías el manejo
de la pandemia veamos que en uruguay por
ahora tienen un muerto cada 100.000
habitantes mientras argentina tiene 25
muertos cada 100.000 habitantes pero por
otro lado también están especulando
algunos con la posibilidad de beneficios
fiscales en ese país y tal vez si
empiecen a ver solicitudes de residencia
para quedarse preso lo iremos viendo con
el tiempo si fueron para quedarse por un
periodo de tiempo durante la pandemia o
se están planeando quedarse en forma
permanente en el vecino país
lluís rápidamente hay enfrentamientos en
las calles entre entre los ciudadanos y
las autoridades ya ha generado también
controversia a nivel internacional
rápidamente y puntual por favor si
estamos en la tercera noche de protestas
en colombia que dejan ya al menos 13
muertos es todo viene después de que el
martes falleciese el abogado javier
ordóñez tras recibir más de 10 descargas
eléctricas y después en una estación de
policía ser golpeado contundentemente en
la cabeza esto demuestra el hartazgo
social que se ha ido acumulando durante
estos meses en constante
enfrentamientos pequeños entre la
policía y manifestantes y la población
colombiana sobre todo especialmente por
unos comparendos que alcanzan que son
superiores una multa por no llevar el
tapabocas por ejemplo es superior al
salario mínimo colombiano que está
alrededor de unos 260 dólares muchas
gracias luis por este reporte gracias a
nuestros corresponsables a ustedes por
la sintonía aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa
[Música]